[Music]
my next guest my next guest is a
comedian who can be seen live at comedy
works in denver colorado november 2nd
through the 4th please welcome the very
funny sean o'connor
[Applause]
[Music]
hey everybody how are you guys doing
tonight nice to meet you
i am sean o'connor this is my energy
let's get used to it
all right good
was a really smart kid growing up i
don't know if any of you guys are smart
but i was uh here's how i know i was
smart i quit karate as a child
so i wouldn't have a ponytail as an
adult
now you guys know that i'm very smart
i have 80d i don't know if any of you
guys have but if you don't get it it is
the best uh
my doctor prescribed me adderall he was
like you can't drink on adderall i was
like no you totally can it makes it
better
i'm like you should know that you're a
doctor
why are you lying
i love adderall because not only does it
help you concentrate but it's also an
appetite suppressant so most of the time
i'm like i could eat dinner right now
or i could read 10 books about birds i
turn into books about birds
guys i know so much about birds
did you guys know a bird is the only
animal you can throw and you're helping
it
you throw a dog you're a monster
you throw a bird you're gonna hear the
word majestic
and what's better than that
i don't understand people get super
muscular like super muscular ripped and
jacked in their muscle areas
and they're not professional athletes
like my little brother's super muscular
ripped and jacked and he says things
like image is everything
and i'm like yeah look at you you're
like a really strong restaurant manager
must be able to lift so many plates of
shrimp
is useless
i took a screenwriting class in college
that was taught by the guy who wrote
mannequin 2 on the move
that happened
that guy would give me notes on
everything i wrote he'd be like this
needs more character development
i'd be like should i make her a
mannequin
because that's what you did twice
talk about something serious i got a i
got arrested in high school which is the
best time to get arrested because it
doesn't count and
what happened was i was at a party and i
was drinking a lot and i was like you
know what i'll do i'll go smoke pot
guys do not go down that road
what happened was i went outside of my
friend's house started smoking pot and
in the suburbs they have these things
called cops
and
[Applause]
they're not always a fun bunch and
so the cop got out of his car and he
said
are you smoking pot
and i'll never forget what i said
i said no and i sprinted as fast i could
he was way faster he caught me
arrested me i went to a catholic high
school guess what guys they hate when
their students get arrested
they tell my parents they're like we're
going to expel your son
unless
you send him to drug counseling of your
choosing
so that summer my parents sent me to a
summer camp
for magicians
and i'm here to say guys it did not work
it just made me way more creative with
how i hid my drugs
[Applause]
[Music]
because now i can never get arrested
because they'd be like oh you mean this
cocaine officer
it's doves
you fly away
i told that joke one time and there was
this guy sitting in the second row when
i hit the punch line he turned to his
friends gave him a high five
and screamed
i'm gonna try that
i thought it was so awesome that this
guy would throw away what was obviously
like years of his drug dealing technique
to incorporate my joke into it
every day now i read the newspaper to
see if he got arrested
for being like oh you mean this cocaine
officer
and then cocaine would just go
everywhere he's like oh right i forgot
to buy the doves
i am so stupid
thank guys
that's great thank you great job good to
see you again